The “Spanish” flu pandemic was the single
worst disease episode in modern world history.
In the space of eighteen months in 1918-1919,
its four epidemic waves killed tens of millions
of people around the globe, ravaging a population
that had already been exhausted by the mass
killing tactics of the War to End All Wars.
In today’s video we will look at the Spanish
flu from three perspectives: first, how did
it spread across the world and what was its
impact on the every day lives of ordinary
individuals; then, we will profile this invisible
killer, seeking to understand its origins
and murderous methods; finally, we will assess
the death toll it inflicted on the human species
and see what can we learn from the experience.
And with that, let’s get into it.
Part I: Long March of the Invisible Tyrant
[Production Note: In addition to the standard
chapter headings I have introduced headings
for Parts I, II and III to better organise
the three main themes.
I suggest the ‘Part’ title cards are presented
as simple white text on a black background,
while the other title cards are displayed
as usual]
A Mysterious Origin Story
The term ‘Spanish’ is of course a misnomer,
it would be more appropriate to call it ‘The
Great Influenza Pandemic of 1918-1919’,
so I will use both terms.
This epidemic did not originate in Spain,
it received this honorary citizenship only
because Spain was a neutral country in WWI
and its press was free from censorship to
report first about this mysterious disease.
The origins of the pandemic lay elsewhere.
Most contemporary accounts place the first
outbreak at a US Army training base, Camp
Funston, in Kansas, in mid-March 1918.
It is here that this flu virus reaped its
first 48 victims.
But we will never know for certain if that
was the true starting point.
The Online Archive of California holds in
their Spanish Flu section a letter written
by a young recruit, Roy, from Camp Logan,
Texas.
On the 1st of March 1918 he laments:
"We played another funeral today, one of the
lads from Company 1 died, I knew him real
well."
‘Another’ funeral on the 1st of March?
It seems like young soldiers had been dying
throughout February then.
But the origins of the great flu can be traced
back even earlier than 1918.
As early as 1916 and 1917 army camps in Étaples,
France and Aldershot, England had been ravaged
by an unknown respiratory disease.
At the time it had been described as ‘purulent
bronchitis’, but its symptoms resembled
those of the Spanish flu.
However, these outbreaks did not spread beyond
the two military bases and had died down by
April 1917.
Historian Mark Humphries of Canada's Memorial
University of Newfoundland in 2014 proposed
another origin story.
Humphries found archival evidence that a respiratory
illness that struck northern China in November
1917 was identified a year later by Chinese
health officials as identical to the Spanish
flu.
From China, British officials organised the
transport of 94,000 labourers to the Western
Front, via North America, as part of an auxiliary
corps in charge of digging trenches and maintaining
supply lines.
The labourers were sailed to Vancouver on
the Canadian West Coast, then loaded onto
trains to Halifax on the East Coast, from
which they could be sent to Europe.
The press was forbidden from reporting on
these transports and the trains had been sealed:
both were meant as a precaution, to protect
the labourers from widespread anti-Chinese
sentiment.
But the un-intended effect may have been to
further contagion amongst the auxiliary’s
ranks.
Some 3,000 of them, while travelling through
Canada, were quarantined with flu-like symptoms.
And of course, newspapers could not publish
a single word about it, meaning the infected
trains could continue their eastwards run.
The Chinese laborers arrived in southern England
by January 1918 and were sent to France, where
a Hospital at Noyelles-sur-Mer recorded hundreds
of their deaths from respiratory illness.
Whether because of the Chinese Labourers,
or US Army recruits, large movements of troops
were accountable for the rapid diffusion of
the virus.
Between May and July the Great flu had spread
across virtually the whole of North and Central
America, Europe, and Asia.
The Pravda in Russia wrote that ‘The Spanish
Lady’ had thrown a whole town, Murom, into
disarray.
The Times of India reported that
"Nearly every house ... has some of its inmates
down with [influenza] fever and every office
is bewailing the absence of clerks,”
The epidemic had an obvious impact on the
war, which was still raging especially on
the Western Front.
German General Erich Ludendorff complained
that
"It was a grievous business having to listen
every morning to the Chiefs of Staff’s recital
of the number of influenza cases, and their
complaints about the weakness of their troops.”
He would later even blame the failure of his
Spring Offensive on the virus.
This was the First Wave, which seemed bad
at the time.
And it actually was pretty bad.
But it was nothing compared to what was to
come.
Voices in The Second Wave
During the first sweep of the Spanish Lady,
the influenza virus probably went through
a mutation process which made it much deadlier.
This enhanced killer made its first appearance
in late August of 1918, when the Second Wave
took off almost simultaneously from three
major wartime ports: Boston, USA; Brest, France;
and Freetown, Sierra Leone.
Form the three ports, thousands of sailors,
soldiers and civilian travellers became vectors
for the virus.
Aboard their ship, in a matter of weeks the
infected spread the disease across the four
corners of the Globe, with only a handful
of remote locations being spared the ordeal.
The Second Wave dragged down throughout the
whole of Autumn and into early Winter of 1919.
The end of the war, on the 11th of November
1918, did not mitigate the onslaught, arguably
it made it worse: millions of soldiers were
demobilised, hundreds of thousands of PoW’s
returned home, carrying an unwanted stowaway
inside their lungs.
A whole generation of young men had been decimated
by artillery, weaponised gas, machine gun
fire … and those who survived were likely
to die because of a single droplet of saliva.
It took only one single virus, inside a single
droplet out of 40,000 ejected by a single
sneeze … and like that, you were infected.
The feeling of the fragility of life in those
times is captured by the every-day correspondence
of ordinary people.
In September 1918 a Post Office worker in
Plymouth, Massachusetts wrote to his wife
about the gruelling conditions he worked in
to ensure a continuing service, amidst the
constant death caused by the flu:
“I have some more very bad news to write
you and I guess if things keep on that by
the end of the year there will be nobody left
in town.
Harold Ashley died yesterday …Harold will
be buried just as soon as his body arrives
and there will be no funeral
On Friday we had seven funerals and Saturday
about as many, so you see what we are up against.
In Brockton three days last week there was
one every hour”
On the 11th of October, a recruit in training
in Michigan wrote to a friend that in his
camp
’50 die every day from it’
From the 16th to the 27th of October, a series
of letter from Mrs Alma Sr to her daughter
Alma Jr show how unbreakable can a mother’s
love be.
Writing from Rochester, New York, Mrs Alma
worries that her daughter is safe and healthy,
in her college in Ontario, Canada.
Some of the motherly advice may resonate with
what you hear these days:
“Was just wondering how you were getting
in these days of epidemic - in the Country
it is fierce and so many dying …
Over here is something awful people are dying
and it's awful …
Don't worry or fret because you only can walk
in the yard - be glad you can do that … keep
in fresh air all you can … and keep warm
put your bathrobe on at night … hot lemonade
at night is excellent for influenza.”
Mrs Alma then laments that she cannot help
her other daughter with her little baby, Jane
because she is invalided at home, and that
it is
“impossible to get nurses”
While worrying about the well-being of her
daughters and doing what she could to help
her granddaughter, Mrs Alma was ill with cancer.
Maybe unable to access medical care earlier
because of the pandemic, she was eventually
hospitalised on the 27th of October, and died
on the 6th of November.
On the 31st of October, an official at the
Mayor office of San Francisco took the initiative
to notify his counterpart in Santa Barbara,
about effective public health measures in
his city.
“Sending this for your information because
I have seen the whole terrible effect of epidemic
here, because masks have saved untold suffering
and many deaths, and because Santa Barbara
is my old home city"
The measure in place was simply the universal
wearing of masks.
Three days after the use became general, new
cases in San Francisco dropped by 50%, but
the daily death toll was still above 100.
On the other side of the pond, London was
being stricken as hard as New York State,
California and Ontario.
On the 28th of October 1918, one Mrs Bennett
wrote
“Things here are in a terrible state, this
new flu … taking people off as they walk
along the streets.
In fact, the undertakers can’t turn the
coffins out or bury the people quick enough.
There's families of 6 & 7 in one house lay
dead.”
On the same day, an American soldier stationed
in France wrote to his mother, reassuring
her that the situation where he was stationed
was not as bad as it was at another base,
Camp Sherman.
He also mentioned that
“The French people have a way of treating
[the flu], they make some kind of tea of some
kind of leaves....”
Unfortunately, he did not provide the recipe.
The Last Waves
Another series of letters from an American
private provides a good example of acquired
immunity.
Martin Aloysius Culhane, known as ‘Al’,
was stationed at Camp Forrest, Georgia, form
where he wrote to his brother and to his best
friend.
While he mourned the death of his ‘bunkie’,
Thomas, he was in relative high spirit: he
had survived the Great pandemic, not once,
but twice!
“I am still in quarantine but will be released
today.
I am feeling great and the two day's rest
has done me a world of good”
His main concern was that while in quarantine
he had been
“neglecting the ladies”.
So he asked his friend Cliff to check on Ursula,
Ella, Ida, Mary Rose, Mary English and Mary
Anne.
So, was ‘Al’ simply lucky, in love and
in health?
There is strong evidence suggesting that exposure
to previous waves of the Spanish flu could
generate acquired immunity in those who had
been infected, but had survived.
A research led by Dr JM Barry from Tulane
and Xavier Universities, Louisiana, highlighted
how the First Wave of the Spanish Flu was
characterized by a high number of cases, but
had a lower fatality rate than the Second
Wave.
By looking at medical records of US soldiers,
he estimated that the fatality rate during
the lethal Autumn sweep was 4.7%.
In the Spring, it had been only 1.1%.
However, the deadly barrage of the Second
Wave had largely spared those who had been
previously exposed in the Spring!
The case of Camp Dodge illustrates this perfectly:
Here, one regiment of troops had experienced
the First Wave, while another regiment had
escaped it.
Among those exposed in the Spring, only 6.6%
became sick with flu in the Autumn.
In contrast, among the troops not exposed
in the spring, a staggering 48.5% fell ill
during the Second Wave!
Now, the witness accounts and the research
mentioned so far may refer to America or Europe,
but this should not give the impression that
other continents were spared.
Let’s go back to September 1918.
This is when Indian troops who had served
on the Western front returned home.
The first outbreak took place in Bombay, where
mortality rate was more than 5% of all population.
The Spanish Lady had now access to access
to a huge new territory, densely populated,
serviced by a large railway network.
The perfect storm, in other words.
In just a month, the flu had spread to Sri
Lanka and to the Northern provinces, reaping
an estimated 14 to 18 Million lives, the highest
death toll recorded in a single country.
Also in September, a troop transport ship
sailed off Bombay to Mombasa, Kenya.
Of course, the virus was a stow away.
The infection spread to members of the Kenyan
Carrier Corps, who were just about to be demobilised.
As they returned home, they carried the contagion
inland, adding to the death toll caused by
the other two major African outbreaks, originating
in Sierra Leone and South Africa.
Most of Africa had been spared the First Wave,
meaning that the Autumn burst had cruelly
scorched through the continent: towns like
Kimberley, Addis Ababa, and Windhoek lost
over 4 percent of their populations to flu.
The bulk of the victims were aged between
18 and 40: so, the effect on society was disastrous
in terms of loss of labour, reproductive capacity,
and family structures.
It was a sudden demographic, social and economic
catastrophe without precedent.
Back in India, by November the rate of contagion
had largely subsided.
It is speculated that this was due to the
onset of the monsoon season, as humid climates
are not favourable to flu viruses.
The march of the invisible tyrant, nonetheless,
continued eastwards, reaching China.
Until now, the majority of the victims worldwide
had been aged 15 to 34, an age bracket unusual
for influenza pandemics.
We’ll find out later why this group was
particularly targeted.
In China, the Second Wave preyed on an even
younger cohort, children aged 11 to 15.
Overall, however, the mortality rate here
was much lower compared to India and other
Countries.
Researchers from the Hong Kong Institute of
Chinese Medicine theorize that traditional
Chinese medicine may have played a part.
Remedies put in place by local government
included spraying houses with limewater, or
burning rhubarb and root stalks of the Atractylodes
flower to disinfect the air.
For prevention, villagers were advised to
drink mung bean soup and rock sugar.
Another explanation is the one hinted at earlier:
since the pandemic had originated there, Chinese
citizens had already developed an immunity
to it.
By the early months of 1919 the rage of the
pandemic was relatively tamed, and I stress
relatively.
The early Spring of the year saw a third wave
making the rounds throughout the globe.
Although it did not match the speed, reach
and virulence of the Autumn wave, it was still
deadly.
On March 5th 1919, a young Canadian man, Harold,
wrote to a friend in Illinois:
"There are an awful lot of people dying just
now on account of the flu.
A little girl next door was buried today and
there is a lady up the street that is pretty
sick and my little sister is just getting
over it …
So I guess it is pretty near my turn …”
We don’t know if Harold made it or not.
The third sweep was followed by a Fourth Wave,
less severe, which lingered on in locations
such as Scandinavia, the South Atlantic and
Sicily.
It is still debated whether this was a mutated
strain of the original virus, or a new one
altogether.
One of the last documented victims of the
Fourth Wave was a little girl from Palermo,
Rosalia Lombardo.
She had been born on the 13th of December
1918, at the height of the Autumn flu in Europe,
and passed away aged only two, on the 6th
of December 1920.
Her father, aggrieved by such a sudden and
meaningless death, asked for her body to be
preserved as if she were still asleep.
One century later, Rosalia can still be seen
sleeping in the Capuchin Catacombs of Palermo.
This unwitting memorial to the Great Pandemic
is now known as ‘the most beautiful mummy
in Europe’.
Part II: Profiling the Killer
One of a Kind
At a high level, flu viruses are divided into
four types, from A to D. And type A’s can
be divided into further sub-categories, depending
on the subtypes of two proteins present on
their surface: hemagglutinin, ‘H’, and
neuraminidase, ‘N’.
The influenza virus responsible for the 1918
pandemic was identified as being a Type A,
H1N1 subtype.
Viruses of the A, H1N1 type are actually quite
common amongst humans.
But we’ll find out later what made this
specific virus so special – and so lethal.
A 2001 study suggested that the 1918 virus
may have originated in swine hosts, before
moving onto humans.
But another investigation in 2005 suggested
a more likely source: birds.
The enteric tracts of waterfowl such as ducks
and geese are known to be the reservoirs for
all known influenza A viruses.
For those of you not au fait with physiology
or anatomy, the enteric tract is the nervous
system that regulates digestion.
Within the original host, let’s say a duck,
the virus may mutate over time: either independently,
or by recombination with a gene segment from
a different virus.
Now that the pathogen is mutated, it is ready
to jump species, usually from avian to mammal,
and attack a new type of cells, for example
those lining the lungs.
This is almost certainly what happened to
the Spanish flu strain, and I should stress
almost.
In two separate studies of 1999 and 2005,
Oxford University and the Atlanta Centre for
Disease Control were able to reconstruct the
genome of the original virus.
What they found is that the 1918 influenza
was composed of 8 gene segments, all distinct
from any of the hundreds of both avian and
mammalian viruses collected since 1917.
This … little fella… was literally one
of a kind!
This unique quality made it impossible to
ascertain who or what could have been the
original host of the virus, and how it had
evolved into its lethal final form.
Another clue: normally, outbreaks of viruses
with an avian origin are preceded by large
die-off of poultry or other bird population
… but this was not the case for the 1918
pandemic.
The initial animal host, the patient alpha,
is still unidentified.
Modus Operandi
One thing was clear about the 1918 H1N1 virus:
its virulence and pathogenicity were unrivalled,
compared to other viruses which both preceded
it and followed it.
To clarify these points:
Pathogenicity is defined as the ability of
an infectious agent to cause disease or damage
in a host.
Virulence, on the other hand, is a measure
of the severity of said disease.
A microorganism can be pathogenic, or not.
If it is pathogenic, its virulence can vary
from mild to fatal.
Let’s look at pathogenicity first.
Contemporary, ‘normal’ flu viruses require
the presence of the enzyme trypsin in their
human host, in order to replicate.
The 1918 virus instead could proliferate even
in the absence of trypsin, making it more
pathogenic than other viruses.
The Spanish flu also displayed a unique capacity
to proliferate at high rates inside human
bronchial cells – and that explains its
virulence.
Little by little, a picture of the killer
was emerging, thanks to modern researchers
in the role of crime scene investigators,
or criminal profilers.
The next step was to understand how Mr Type
A H1N1 of the 1918 class actually killed:
what was its modus operandi.
Enter Dr David Morens of the National Institute
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases in Maryland.
In 2007 he reviewed autopsy records for influenza
casualties in the 1918-1919 period and identified
two overlapping syndromes which caused the
death of the infected hosts.
In at least 85% to 90% of cases, patients
suffered from an acute viral infection, that
spread down the respiratory trait, causing
severe tissue damage inside the lungs.
The damaged tissue was then invaded by a so-called
secondary invasion.
Not viruses this time, but bacteria: pathogens
like Streptococcus Pneumoniae or Staphylococcus
aureus would invade the damaged lungs, causing
cases of aggressive bronchopneumonia.
In other words, the killing virus did not
act alone, but had accomplices.
The actions of these cohorts eventually led
to severe pulmonary haemorrhage and necrosis
– or tissue death – within the bronchi.
The remaining 10 to 15% of fatal cases suffered
from ARDS, or ‘acute respiratory distress—like
syndrome’.
Patients with this syndrome could be easily
identified by their peculiar blue-grey facial
discoloration: a typical sign of drowning.
Because that’s essentially what was happening:
the virus caused the pulmonary blood vessels
to exude huge amounts of thin, watery droplets,
which clogged the lung tissue.
In other words: these patients were drowning
in a liquid created by their own bodies.
Now that we have clarified the modus operandi
of this killer, we have to understand its
peculiar choice of victims.
Normally flu epidemics claim most of their
victims among the elderly, but the Spanish
Flu had a clear predilection for a younger
demographic, those aged between 15 and 34.
A lower than expected mortality among the
elderly may have been explained by acquired
immunity.
Individuals aged 40 and over, may have been
exposed to one of the three flu pandemics
of the 19th Century, in 1830, 1847 or 1889.
Although not everybody agrees: unlike the
1918 strain, these previous viruses did not
cause aggressive bronchopneumonia nor lung
haemorrhage.
We may have more convincing answers explaining
why the death rate was higher among the young
ones.
Dr Robert Snelgrove from Imperial College
London, among others, has theorised the notion
of the so-called ‘cytokine storm’.
Cytokines are proteins released by cells to
interact with each other and to trigger specific
processes.
For example, internal inflammation – a common
reaction of the body against infections.
A younger organism would naturally release
more cytokines than and elderly one.
In the case of the Spanish flu, the cells
of infected younger patients released a deleterious
excess of cytokines, leading to excessive
inflammation of the lungs, and more importantly,
tissue necrosis.
Ironically, younger, fitter organisms deployed
a stronger reaction to protect themselves
– a reaction which eventually claimed their
lives.
Part III: Assessing the Damage
A Pale Rider
Shortly after the last wave had died down,
the scientific community tried to take stock
of the magnitude of the disaster.
American bacteriologist Edwin Oakes Jordan
was one of the first to calculate the death
toll, which he estimated to be in the vicinity
of 21.5 million.
This number in itself is staggering.
Compare it to the casualties of the Great
War: about 10 Million dead soldiers, killed
over a period of four years and a half.
The Spanish Flu killed twice as many people
over little more than a year.
Now let’s compare it to the world’s population
in 1918.
At that time there were 1.8 Billion on the
planet.
The Spanish flu killed 1.2% of them.
If we apply that ratio to today’s population
we would have a death toll of more than 93
million.
Oakes Jordan’s estimate stood for decades,
but it was later challenged as being too low.
First, a 1986 publication calculated the mortality
in India alone to be at 18 million.
Subsequently, in 1991 authors David Patterson
and Gerald Pyle proposed another estimate,
placing the death toll between 25 and 40 million
victims.
Was that the definitive number?
Probably not.
A 2002 study by Dr Niall Johnson and Dr Juergen
Mueller suggested that previous numbers may
have been underestimated due to common issues
such as missing records, misdiagnosis or death
certificates compiled by non-medical personnel.
Not only that: deaths among indigenous populations
in colonial dominions may have been overlooked,
ignored or simply not reported by colonial
authorities.
Also, most of the reports collected at the
time of the pandemic referred to deaths taking
place during the major wave of Autumn-Winter.
Influenza mortality before and after that
wave may have been ignored or reported under
other causes of death, such as pneumonia.
All in all, considering all these instances
of under-reporting, Johnson and Mueller placed
their estimate in a range from 50 up to 100
million dead.
Let’s stop for a second to consider that.
100 million dead.
The entire population of the US at that time
was just 108 million.
The whole of Latin America only had 57 million
inhabitants.
Sometimes numbers may not be enough to represent
the sheer scale of a tragedy, so think about
it this way:
in a matter of few months, one USA or two
Latin Americas had been completely wiped out
by a microscopic being which had likely originated
in the bowels of a duck.
In all honesty, the more we researched the
death toll, the more we found conflicting
accounts, ranging from the top count of 100
million, down to the no less tragic 18 million.
We will likely never know how many people
did not get to see their next year because
of the Great killer of 1918 and 1919.
A Tragedy of the Unborn
In our grim research we also came across an
even bleaker notion: how many victims didn’t
even get to see their first day of life.
In other words: the impact of the Great Influenza
on unborn children.
Dr Bloom-Feshbach of Mount Sinai School of
Medicine, New York, and her team have examined
the relationship between influenza and birth
rates during the Great pandemic in the US,
Denmark, Sweden, and Norway.
The analysis showed a decline in birth rates
for all examined populations in spring of
1919.
This decline represented a 15% drop below
baseline levels recorded before the pandemic.
This ‘natality depression’ reached its
maximum levels about 6 months after the pandemic
peak of the previous autumn.
This suggested that the decline in birth could
be attributed to a surge in first trimester
miscarriages, which affected about 10% of
all women who were pregnant at the peak of
the pandemic.
The conclusion of Bloom-Feshbach and team
is that the virus was directly responsible
for the miscarriages.
And the 10% incidence rate may have been an
underestimation.
As they point out, a 1919 report of 1350 pregnant
women with influenza, showed how more than
a quarter of them had miscarried.
The concept of so many babies not even being
born is hard to accept.
But the same study revealed another finding,
which shows that regardless of the disaster,
our species is always capable of bouncing
back up.
The dip in birth rates in spring of 1919 was
followed by
‘a compensatory natality increase in late
autumn 1919 and early spring 1920, when natality
significantly exceeded the expected rates.’
The resurgence of births confirmed that fertility
was not permanently impacted.
Humanity could slowly rebuild itself, lick
the wounds inflicted by the double tragedy
of the Great War and the Great Pandemic, and
slowly return to normal.
Return to a daily life, and a historical period
that was going to be devoid of war, famine
and disease, at least according to some leaders
… a period which turned out to be only a
20-year truce.
But that’s another story.
Could It Happen Today?
Back in 2004, a team at the Harvard School
of Public Health had modelled the transmissibility
patterns of the 1918 virus, more precisely
they calculated its reproductive number, ‘R’,
in relation to its serial interval, ‘v’.
The ‘R’ number tells how many secondary
patients are produced by each primary patient.
The ‘v’ value is the average time – expressed
in days - between a primary and secondary
case.
The team evaluated that the 1918 virus had
an ‘R0’ value of 2 to 4.
In lay terms: an infected patient could infect
four more patients in less than a day.
This may sound like a high rate of contagion,
however the researchers pointed out that this
was not that high, in relation to other influenza
subtypes.
In their estimation, a similar pandemic could
be prevented by vaccinating or administering
antiviral prophylaxis to 50–75% of the population.
Sounds easy, right?
Well, this depends on how well prepared a
national health system is, when it comes to
facing such emergencies.
Stockpiles of vaccines and antivirals may
or may not be enough – or these drugs may
not be available at all, still progressing
through the early stages of a clinical trial.
There is the added problem that flu viruses
may be transmitted before the onset of defining
signs and symptoms.
In other words: people infect each other even
before they appear to be sick.
So, what is left to do?
I will quote directly from the clinical paper:
“This implies that measures that generally
reduce contacts between persons, regardless
of infection status, may be our most powerful
protection against a pandemic until adequate
vaccine and antiviral medicines can be produced,
at which point mass-vaccination and prophylaxis
may be more effective than targeted approaches.”
I hope that by the time you watch this video
the current Covid-19 pandemic is a thing of
the past.
If it’s not, well I hope that this message
resonated with you.
You have heard it a million times, we all
have heard it.
Until we are through this emergency, staying
at home is our most powerful protection.
Stay at home, stay safe, and thank you for
watching.